E
GOOD THINGS TO COME.
TREY: PLEAING A LIFE IS A
TOUGH JOB EVEN ON THE DAYS
DO YOU MAKE IT HOME ALIVE.
PAY IS NOT GOOD, HOURS ARE
LONG.
AND PEOPLE SOMETIMES ARE NOT
HAPPY TO SEE YOU, THERE ARE
NOT THAT MANY JOBS
WHERE YOU NEED A BULLET
PROOF VEST AND A FIREARM TO
GO TO WORK.
IT HAS BECOME MORE DIFFICULT
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THE
RHETORIC.
IT WAS DEFUND THE POLICE.
THE MEDIA BOUGHT IT.
THAT IS WHAT WE HEARD,
DEFUND THE POLICE, EXCEPT
THE VOTERS DONE LIKE IT,
VOTERS KNOW WE NEED POLICE
AS LONG AS THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO BREAK THE LAW AND HAVE
NO REGARD FOR LIFE, PROPERTY
OR WELL BEING OF OFFICERS,
WE HAVE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE
OF THE HUMAN CONDITION IS
GLAWED.
FLAWED.
WE HAVE MILITARIES AND
BORDERS AND DOORS AND LOCKS
BECAUSE THE HUMAN CONDITION
IS FLAWED.
DESPITE THE OBVIOUS, SOME ON
THE LEFT WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE STILL, INSTEAD OF
CALLING A COP WHEN SOMEONE
IS BREAKING INTO YOUR HOME,
THEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO CALL
A SOCIAL WORKER, A
PSYCHOLOGIST OR A LIFE
COACH.
LOGICALLY THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT WAS A
TRAIN WRECK, POLITICALLY
WORSE, THE SMART POLITICIANS
TO LEFT FIGURED OUT, WE
NEED TO STOP TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING AS STUPID AS
DEFUNDING THE POLICE, THIS
IS A DUMB IDEA.
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
PROTESTERS TO TALK ABOUT US
DEFUNDING POLICE, MOST
STOPPED TALKING ABOUT IT
THEY FORGOT NO TELL
CONGRESSWOMAN COREY BUSH,
WATCH AND LISTEN.
>> THE THING ABOUT DEFUND
POLICE WE HAVE TO TELL THE
INTERNARRATIVE.
PEOPLE HERE DEFUND POLICE,
SAN JOSE, SAY REALLOCATE,
SAY DIVEST, REMOVE, BUT
STILL THE SAME THING.
>> IF YOU COULD DO IT AGAIN
WOULD YOU STILL DOUBLE DOWN
OR USE THAT SLOGAN DEFUND
THE POLICE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU WOULD?
TREY: I'M NOT SURE WHERE TO
START.
SHE SAID WE CAN'T GET CAUGHT
UP ON THE WORDS, WHAT ELSE
WOULD WE GET CAUGHT UP ON
THIS WHAT ELSE WOULD WE
FOCUS ON?
BODY LANGUAGE, WORDS MATTER,
THAT IS WHY WE USE THEM TO
COMMUNICATE.
HOW ARE WE TO KNOW YOU
PREFER WORD DIVEST OVER
DEFUND?
DIVEST IS A WORD TOO.
SHE WANT US TO SAY DIVEST
THE POLICE.
WELL, THE WORD MEANS TO
DEPRIVE.
TO STRIP AWAY TO TAKE AWAY.
THAT IS LIKE DEFUND, BUT
WORSE.
SHE SAID PEOPLE SPEND TOO
MUCH TIME ON THE WORD
DEFUND, THERE ARE ONLY 3
WORDS IN THE PHRASE, DEFUND
THE POLICE, THE DOES NOT
WARRANT WERE TIME, WE COULD
TALK ABOUT POLICE BUT AT
POINT A REPORTER MIGHT ASK
YOU, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO
WITH THE POLICE, THERE WE
ARE RIGHT BACK AT THE
WORD DEFUND, NOW DIVES